MALE SPEAKER: So let
me switch to English
because Bridgette will
be speaking in English.
Bridgette represents
Google for Entrepreneurs,
so she'll tell you a
few words about that.
And she wants to share
her ideas on what
data means for entrepreneurs.
So please, Bridgette,
come onstage.
BRIDGETTE BEAM: Now, hello.
I'm Bridgette, Bridgette Beam.
I work on this team,
Google for Entrepreneurs.
I'm based out of Google's
headquarters in California.
A little bit about my
team before I get started.
I don't want to bore you too
long, but it's a great team.
We basically focus on how Google
can foster entrepreneurship
around the world.
How we can get you the
resources, the programs,
the partners, the opportunities
you need to be successful.
This is our website-- if
you ever have a chance,
it's actually super useful.
We put on these classes
online which are free.
These are normally paid classes.
A lot of them are
taught by Googlers,
and product managers, marketers.
Also, many of them are taught
by experts outside of Google.
We release one every
week, pretty much.
So if you follow us on Google+,
we put up new content all
the time.
We also have great events.
So if you ever
have a chance, you
can check out some of the
events like this that are here.
Again, we also post
those to Google+.
So if you guys are
interested, it's really about
bringing Googlers
and our talent to you
to help you be successful, and
that's what today is about.
So please, if you have
questions, ask them.
All the Googlers in the room,
can you please raise your hand?
See, there's a lot.
The ratio's quite high, beware.
Just kidding.
But there are a lot of
people here to help you,
so please ask questions.
First of all, who is willing
to volunteer and tell me
why you're here?
Or give me your pitch--
what does your company do?
Yeah?
OK, here we go.
RAPHAEL: Hi, everybody.
I'm Raphael from
[INAUDIBLE] Show,
and I'm here to learn
a lot from Googlers.
And first of all, I
have one question--
why does Google exist?
BRIDGETTE BEAM: Why does it?
RAPHAEL: Yeah.
BRIDGETTE BEAM: What
does your company do?
RAPHAEL: My company,
we're making [INAUDIBLE].
So it's like a way to take
notes more intelligently.
Thank you.
BRIDGETTE BEAM: All
right, the question
was why Google does this.
It's a good question.
So if you think about
Google as a search engine,
we need really great
content out there
to make the web really
valuable, right?
If you search and
there's nothing there,
or if you're trying
to find an application
and there's nothing there for
you, it's not very useful.
Google is very much a
platform for other people
to succeed as much
as we succeed.
We only succeed if
entrepreneurs do,
so that's why this
program exists.
Does that make sense?
RAPHAEL: Yeah.
BRIDGETTE BEAM: Cool.
Anybody else want to volunteer?
I promise I'll talk about
something else in a minute,
but I want some examples
for my presentation.
Oh, way in the back.
Can you yell?
TERRY: Yeah.
BRIDGETTE BEAM: All right.
TERRY: Hi, everyone.
My name is Terry, and I am
doing a little recipe platform.
Do you cook? [INAUDIBLE]?
BRIDGETTE BEAM: Yes, a lot.
TERRY: So, you can [INAUDIBLE]
with us with your recipes.
So we buy recipes.
We give you $20.
BRIDGETTE BEAM: He
buys my recipes.
TERRY: Yes, I do.
BRIDGETTE BEAM: $20.
TERRY: So I would
like Google to help
me to make with
Google checkout, and I
would like you to feature
my application with Android
at top.
BRIDGETTE BEAM: OK, is there
a Googler here with Android.
TERRY: I want also to have
a good reference on Google+.
[INAUDIBLE].
Because we need to bring people.
We are going global
so we need your help.
BRIDGETTE BEAM: This guy's going
to be super busy today, running
around to everyone.
OK, sounds good.
Well, what I want
to talk about today,
I am an entrepreneur myself.
I work with two entrepreneurs
very intimately-- one
is my husband, and
one is my mother.
My family has a
ton of businesses.
Everybody is running
around making things,
helping people, doing stuff.
So I on a daily basis actually
help monitor Google+ pages,
AdWords, Analytics,
all of the above.
And so today I actually want to
share with you some of my-- I
don't have very much
time to do this.
I have a full-time job.
It's probably more like
two full-time jobs,
and then this is something
I do on the side.
You're also very, very
busy people, right?
And you need to know
what kind of decisions
to make on a daily basis.
So I'm actually just going to
share a little bit about what
I do every day with my family's
businesses to help them.
And I think it's really valuable
for you as an entrepreneur.
So I want to talk about data.
It's a very hot topic.
Everybody loves to talk
about data and infographics.
But very, very few
of the time did
they find data being useful.
So I'm going to talk
about a few courses first.
Everybody likes numbers, so I'll
share some cool Google numbers
with you.
But essentially, we all
know the world has changed.
There's a blog out there
called Failed Dinners.
Have you guys seen this?
It's basically a bunch of
people, or people on a date,
who go out to dinner
together and they
spend the whole
time on their phone.
People take pictures
of them, and then they
send it to this blog.
It's actually hilarious--
it's very sad, but hilarious.
So some of the reasons
that things have changed
are really because
of these two forces.
One force is
information, so we have
this explosion in information.
You have the ability to
have access to as much data
as you want, right?
If you don't have Analytics,
if you don't look for data sets
around your
industry, you should.
So this is really overwhelming.
If you want to look
at 30 trillion URLs,
I don't even know what trillion
looks like-- never tried.
You want to give me $30
trillion, I'm OK with that.
And then the other force is
really increase in access.
So if you look at these
numbers, think of all the people
who are getting online who
did not get online before.
1.5 million Android
activations per day.
That's a lot more
people coming online
that weren't online before.
These are new customers.
These are different
types of customers.
These are customers accessing
your application, your website,
your business through
multiple devices.
This is a new
segment of the market
that did not exist
that long ago.
How many people remember
life before cell phones?
We had one of
those in a suitcase
in the car when I was
younger for emergencies.
I think it cost
like $40 a minute.
And it was never
charged, it never worked.
I don't think we used it,
but it was really cool.
2 billion internet
searches globally.
And this is actually another
stat that's not up here,
is 15% of searches every
single day are new.
So 15% of the searches that
Google sees on a daily basis
have never been searched
before-- that's actually
very interesting.
You think of search as kind of a
stagnant thing-- people looking
up recipes, people
looking up information
on a very flat level,
but a lot of these
are brand new searches.
So with all this information,
how do we make use of it?
So information is as
powerful, essentially,
as your ability to use it.
So that's what we're
going to talk about today,
is how do you use your data?
And we're even going to
have Vince Surf tell us,
how do you use your data?
He's like godfather,
grandfather of the internet.
He's very nice if you ever
get a chance to meet him.
He's like really cozy,
grandfather-like.
So we're going to
talk two segments.
First is the macro data.
I come from an economics
and math background.
And I love to talk
about economics.
So if you guys want to talk
about that later, I'm happy to.
But macro data, this is all
the forces in the world-- all
of the industry forces, all
of the demographic forces,
the financial forces
that are having
an impact on your business.
So first of all I'm going
to show you some tools.
It's up to you to figure
out how to use them
for your own business.
I used to do this,
I'll do it again.
I'll give you guys one euro
if you do not learn something
during this
presentation, all right?
This is my challenge.
I think I only have
three euros on me,
so I really have to do well.
How many of you guys have heard
of Google Public Data Explorer?
Yes.
I'm doing pretty good already.
So this is a tool.
Basically what it is
is government data,
and data that's publicly
available to the world
but has never been put
in a usable format.
So this is data from the UN.
This is data from the US
government from the eurozone.
So I'm going to go here.
You can just find us at
Google Public Data Explorer.
So I'll show you their
example here on the site.
So this is actually just
showing from the world
economic indicators life
expectancy via country
and over time.
This is pretty cool.
How many of you guys have heard
of Google-- there's a map tool.
I can't think of the map tool.
These are basically
open, public data sets.
This tool you can actually use.
You can actually
ingest your own data
and use these graphical tools.
I'll show you them really
quickly here-- very cool.
This is one on the world, and
this is the one across town.
So if you want to explore data
sets-- and think about this.
Let's imagine that the
country, or the state,
or the region that
you do the best in has
a particular
broadband penetration,
has a particular level
of Android devices,
or iOS devices, has a particular
amount of disposable income.
These are factors like, let's
say a country that you choose
to enter, or a country
you choose to focus on,
you want it to look like what?
How could you find other
countries like that?
How do you measure the forces
that look into the world?
So we can look at
unemployment, which
is super exciting--
you guys don't
have to worry
about unemployment.
You're self-employed-- marriage,
divorce, mortality, population.
But essentially what
you can do in this tool
is find some of the
interesting data that
will have an impact
on your business.
So let's look at
unemployment rates.
Let's imagine you have
an application or a game
that people spend a lot of time
on when they're unemployed--
like Facebook, or tell me an
application that you guys have.
Anyone?
You make games?
Yeah, see, if you
don't have a job,
you're going to play
a lot more games.
So let's pick out
some countries here
and see real quickly
how this changes.
So we can see this over time.
We can see it on the
graph, like I said.
But you can actually
get really detailed.
If you go down to age group,
you can go by age group.
So maybe you want
a certain amount
of people in a certain category.
The other reason that
this tool's great
is if you are going
towards investors,
investors always want
to know about the trends
that impact your business and
how whatever decision you're
making is about those trends.
So it's something to consider.
I'll let you guys do
more with this tool.
Like I said, you can
also ingest data as well
and keep it private.
All right, how
about Google Trends?
How many people have used
Google Trends before?
This is actually
my favorite tool.
I'll show you some really
cool things on it real fast.
And they keep changing it,
so it just got new this week.
This is a problem
with live demos,
people's always
changing products.
So I'd stand up here
and I'm like, hey,
that's not how it
looked yesterday.
I have no idea what happened.
So you just go to Google Trends.
What this is is essentially
Google search data
across all of
Google's platforms.
So we also provide search
for other search engines
as well, like aol.com, a bunch
of those different groups.
So this is a really
accurate search data.
If you go to this
Explore section,
I've got some examples here.
Let's say digital publishing--
I talked to some folks before.
So I talked to a
gentleman earlier
who was interested in
digital publishing.
So if you want to look here, you
can see this graph over time,
and then you can look down
here over city and region.
And then you can see rising
search terms, so potentially
Adobe Digital
Publishing and whatnot.
We can also add locations.
So we're basically taking
all of people's search data
and adding filters so that we
can seek better information.
I'm not sure why
I-- time ranges,
so we'll say the past 12 months.
So I come down here, I can
see over the past 12 months,
the change in time.
If I wanted to, I
could actually do
this where I go
2013, 2012, 2011.
So I can see how this industry
has changed over time.
See what I'm saying?
So we're looking at
digital publishing
over these years in the US.
So what's interesting
about this is how does this
help you make decisions?
If we pull out of,
let's say the US--
I don't know how I
go back to the world,
they just changed this.
OK, we're just going to pretend.
But essentially
what you could do
is, where do you focus
your marketing dollars?
Where do you focus your effort?
These are people who area
already searching for whatever
you're providing, so
it's worth noting.
You could also look
at seasonality.
So it appears that people look
for digital publishing more
in January, less in
June/July, and then
more in the upper ranges.
So if you're going to allocate
your financial resources
or your own personal time,
you would look at that graph.
All right, so this is
my family business.
We do outdoor design, spatial
design, my husband and I. Well,
mostly him-- I just play
with the numbers mostly.
But if you look at,
for us for example,
we have this huge cyclical
factor in our business
that changes how
we spend our money
and how we spend our resources.
We should pretty much just
go on holiday from October
through December.
We should just go on
vacation, not work at all.
There's nothing going on.
Any one else have an example?
Actually, I wanted to
show you one more thing
and this is a real example.
I helped a guy in the US.
He lives in New Orleans.
He runs a macaroon company.
And macaroons are not as
popular outside of France
as they are well-known.
And we were looked
at new areas for him
to create opportunity
for his business.
He says that on a search in the
US, he is completely saturated.
He cannot buy anymore key words.
He can not do anything else.
He can't bid on anything else.
So he looked here
at this map, and we
could see that
actually Canada has
more search volume than the US.
So even though his
business is US,
he should consider
figuring out how
to ship his business
to Canada-- like
to ship some of his
product to Canada.
If he can figure out Australia,
there's a huge opportunity
there as well.
A lot of the times
this is a great tool
to learn about those
new industries,
and also to learn how
people in Australia,
or learn how people
in a certain place
are actually
searching for things.
So if I were you guys,
I would definitely
take time to look at this.
I think it's really great.
Up here, too, which we didn't
look at, is all categories.
So if you're not certain
about what search,
you can actually get
super, super specific.
Well, there's no
macaroons in auto and car.
But if we pull up
auto and car, you
can just even see these
basic search trends.
And then you could actually
look at specific vehicles--
let's say bicycles
and accessories.
So look at the cyclical
nature of this search
is-- bikes go up and down.
So if I were you, I would
spend time on a monthly basis
to look and see
what trends there
are that are affecting your
business, your industry.
On a yearly basis when you're
planning, look at those spikes.
If you have a travel site, look
at what days of the week people
look for travel most.
There is actually
days of the week.
There are actually
days of the month close
to holidays that will factor in.
You want to be smart about
the time and resources
that you spend and
how they map to data.
Good?
Yeah?
OK.
You guys are like, this
girl's just talking, talking.
All right, this is
another really cool tool,
and it's called
Google Think Insights.
Anybody know what this is?
I think I'm going to save
my three Euros that I have.
It's good-- I need to
take the subway back.
So basically what this
is, Google actually
commissions a lot of research
to be done-- research
about industries,
research about the net,
web, how industries
are functioning.
This website has a
ridiculous amount
of things going on for it.
If you go down here,
you can actually
see a lot of case studies,
but there's a ton of data.
So this is actually
going to tell you
all the mobile stats for France.
This is a study on
mobile stats for France.
This is store insights from
case studies, so uses of phones,
buying new cars-- these
are all these studies
that have been commissioned.
55% of smartphone
owners in France
access the internet
daily from their device.
58% of impressions
delivered by YouTube
reach people who
were exposed to TV.
There's a whole repository
of really great data
specific to industries.
You just search for
countries, for industries.
All of the data that
we commission and all
of the industry
reports are there.
So that's super
cool, really concise.
They have a infographic
creator on here as well,
it's very interesting.
At the end of the day, what
I would do is figure out what
sources-- it could not
even be these sources--
are reliable for you for data.
What numbers do you need to
know every month, every quarter,
in order to figure
out how to spend
your time and your money
and your resources,
and how to make your
products better?
This is another one
which I won't go through,
but it's focused on mobile
trends and mobile devices.
It's called Think Mobile,
or Our Mobile Planet.
It's actually called
Our Mobile Planet.
It's also a site
created by Google
that has a ton of
mobile-specific trends
and data.
If you think about all these
marketplaces in the world,
there are often cheaper ways
for you to get customers.
There's Chrome Web Store,
there's the Google Apps
Marketplace, there's a
whole bunch of these.
Also a lot of good marketplaces
to get things done cheaper.
So at 99designs, this is a
marketplace for designers,
this is about your
data as a company.
How do you deal with your data?
How do you make sense of it?
So this is always one
of my favorite examples.
You can't tell
very well on this,
but who knows this
top box in Google?
It's basically our most coveted,
most prized position right
on Google.
If you can manage to bid and
also have a high quality score,
you can be on the
very top of Google.
The color of that
box-- anybody want
to tell me what the
color, you can't see it
very well here, but
the color of that box?
Anybody?
Color?
It's kind of like pink.
Kind of fleshy, like peach.
It's pretty ugly, right?
Like, who would have guessed
that the most expensive
real estate on our
site would be peach?
I would never guess
this-- seems terrible.
Actually, over the years
that color has changed.
I mean, hues of the same
color-- blues, greens, oranges,
yellows, all different colors.
And the reason is
because we have goals.
Every website, everything
on your website
or your application
should have a goal.
The goal of our most
important real estate
is to do two things.
It is to, first of
all, not annoy you.
If this was bright red
or fluorescent green,
you'd be like, oh my
goodness, this is awful.
I hate Google.
That is the worst color ever.
And you would go to use some
other search engine, which
I don't even know
what's out there.
But the other goal is
to make money, right?
We want people, if this
is a good advertisement,
to choose to click
on it, correct?
So those are the two goals.
So with those two
goals in mind, this
was the color that
we came up with.
In the short-term, if
we made this hot pink,
we could probably
get more people
to click on it for two
days, and then they
would never come back.
Whatever application
or website you have,
the most important elements
of your site you have to test.
You have to try
different things.
I would never have
chosen this color--
my instinct would be wrong.
Through the data, this is the
color that we have chosen,
because it achieves our
two goals correctly.
So now I'm going to
play a little game.
Everybody ready
to play this game?
I love games.
And we're going to talk about
how wrong your intuition is.
This is the point of this game.
Isn't that a great game?
The point of the game
is for you to be wrong.
So back in 2008 when Obama
ran for President in the US,
there was a group that helped
him optimize his website.
They used a tool called
Website Optimizer, which
no longer exists.
It's now called
Content Experiments.
It's in Analytics.
You want me to write that
down for you, I will--
it's very complicated.
There's also a non-Google
product called Optimize Link.
Basically what it allows
you to do is ABC test.
So to test different versions
of your sites towards a goal.
A lot of people test their
website and have no goal.
If you have no goal, you should
just shut it down and go home.
So the goal of this site
was to get more people
to sign up to volunteer, which
you can see at the bottom,
and to get more people
to donate money.
And they also wanted volunteers.
So the goal is he wants
people to come to this site,
take action.
And then he wants them
to subsequently continue
on that site, donate money,
volunteer, those things.
So you guys are
all going to vote.
There's two things that were
tested-- the large image which
you can see there and
then this red button.
So I'm going to show
you first the images.
You're going to vote
on one through three.
I'm going to show
you four buttons,
and then we're going to
see who gets it right.
There's nothing to
win except awesome.
So who votes number one?
OK, great.
Who votes number two?
Who votes number three?
OK.
All right, you guys ready?
So these are the options.
Who votes the button Sign Up
is the most effective button?
One guy, two guys, good.
Way to stick with
your conviction.
Number two, Learn More?
OK, a few more.
Number three, Join Us Now?
Solid.
Number four, Sign Up Now?
So what I'm going to show
you is a very old interface
of the Website Optimizer.
So what we can see
here is the combination
that was most effective is
the family image, which I'll
go back to, and then
the button Learn More.
And the results of this,
so the delta, what we mean
is the trajectory of the
first site versus the end
result of the second site.
So the difference was actually
2.8 more subscriptions,
2.8 million people signed up,
$57 million more was donated,
based on a button and an image.
So the original
one-- I'll show you
this one was actually the
original one right here.
It looks good, right?
It doesn't look like the family
image, which we'll go back to.
That doesn't look $57 million
more awesome, does it?
I mean, it definitely
doesn't, but it actually was.
So my message here is, you
have to trust the data.
Sometimes our intuition
is that we made a website.
We made an application and
it's amazing, and we love it.
And your mom loves it,
and your wife loves it,
and your girlfriend loves it.
But the reality is
if the users love it.
Small changes can make a
huge impact on your sites.
My recommendation
is if you're going
to test, test the
most important things.
If you notice, he didn't
change the entire site.
Even though it looks like
it, the fields are the same.
It's just the image
and the button
because that's what matters.
So things to test on your
site, the more simple
the better, the less
text the better, the less
fields the better.
Consolidating the
first experience-- so
this was the first experience.
I'm sure after this you had
to sign up for something
else-- you had to enter a credit
card, you had to do something
to pay this person.
But the reality is that first
experience, that entry point,
was really easy
and it was tested.
It was something
that was data-driven.
So now that I've convinced
you to all test your websites,
how many people use
Google Analytics in here?
It's free and it's amazing.
So I would definitely use it.
I use it.
I love it.
How I use this
tool functionally,
I also use AdWords.
So every day I get an email.
There's custom reports.
You can still have custom
reports in Analytics.
And I only get two numbers
sent to me every day,
because there's so
much data in Analytics.
When you get in there,
you're like, whoa,
this is really confusing
and I don't even
know what I care about anymore.
Before you open your
Analytics account,
you should write
down-- literally,
not joking-- write down the
questions that you have.
Like, where is my
company doing the best?
How much of my cost
per conversion?
Where's my traffic coming from?
Which of the social
media outlets I'm doing
are not just bringing
the most traffic,
but bringing the
most conversions?
You need to think about
what data is actually
meaningful to your
business, and the rest of it
just worry about on
a quarterly basis.
Because you honestly just can't
ingest that much information,
I can't, on a daily basis.
So I set up automated
emails, customer
reports every single day-- I get
cost per conversion every day,
and basically the
number of conversions.
And then on a weekly basis,
I look up other information,
because that's really
all I care about.
Everything else is just noise.
It's useful noise, but
it's not useful every day.
It's not useful
every minute to me.
So I would think about
that with Analytics.
Do, do, do set up
customer reporting.
It'll come to your email or
your phone or whatever you want.
And think about if you had to
have two pieces of information
every morning that would
help you make a better
business, what would
they be, or the three?
And narrow it down,
because it will
help you drive better customers,
better users-- whatever
it is that you're
looking to do, it'll
make the customer experience
and your experience better.
So this is just a
random tip of the day.
If you have internal
search-- how many people
have internal search on
their website or application,
whatever they're working on?
People never look at
internal search on Analytics.
It's basically if you
have a search box inside
of your actual website, those
are people telling you exactly
what they're looking for and
that they cannot find it.
If you match that, plus if
you were to come to your site,
there's a lot of
interesting analysis
you can do there on
an individual basis.
So I could consider doing that.
Last area.
I promise I will sit down.
This is really
about social, even
though I didn't put social.
You have a community
of people, hopefully,
like a social community
and other community
that are influencers.
Most people treat, not only
every single social media,
but every single user the same.
That is completely wrong.
This is Google Ripples,
which is in Google+.
Essentially what it shows
is when I post something--
this is not me posting because
I'm not the Dalai Lama, which
is actually the
person who posted
this which is kind of weird.
But essentially, when I post
something, who are the people
that are actually sharing
who are having the biggest
influence?
Those people are influencers.
Those are my salesmen.
Those are my marketers.
Those are my people
who are out there
selling my products for me.
I should not ignore them.
They should be different.
They're literally
three salesmen,
three marketing people to you.
So I will tell you a
little lesson here.
This is Google Docs.
We have people
every single day who
are not employed
by Google who spend
hours and hours, literally
their entire day almost,
contributing to the
Google Docs forum.
They are not Google employees,
they just love our products.
They are just like
those people who
are here who are influencers.
They're the same
people who are really
in love with our products.
We send them swag.
We send them tickets to Google
I/O. When there's a problem,
we call them.
We have their email addresses.
We engage with these
people because they
are our front line.
They are the people who are
making our products better.
We call them up-- how
do we fix the products?
What's going on?
Do you see an issue here?
Do you see a problem there?
You need to take care
of the people who
are taking care of you,
and those influencers.
So if you have a lot of people
who re-share your posts,
your tweets, whatever it
is, don't ignore them.
Get in touch with them
individually and say,
hey, I want your
product feedback.
I want to have a
relationship with you.
I want to talk to you.
Because they are
literally free employees.
These are people who are working
every day to make Docs better
without our guidance, so
do not ignore those people.
And those people
are in your data.
So if you don't take time
to look at the data that's
influencing your business,
you will not find them--
so we recommend that you do.
This is my last but best slide.
The other thing I think about
with data is a lot of people
look at crowd source funding
as a way to make money.
How many of you guys have
ever had a crowd source
funding campaign?
You guys know what
crowd source funding is?
So essentially you make a
video pitch about your product.
You put it online.
This is a site called Indiegogo
which is actually global.
You can actually fundraise here.
You send it out there,
you try to send it
to your whole network and
get people to submit funds
to your project, or
your business idea,
or whatever you're
doing-- like Kickstarter.
Often though what people
do is if you donate,
let's say, five euro--
I think this guy was
$5-- he will actually
send you the first version
of his product for free, or
he'll give you early access
to the application.
These are people who are willing
to pay for a product that
does not exist and
may never exist.
This is real
customer validation.
This is people who are willing
to pay for your product
before you've created it.
That's data.
That's data about
$62,572 worth of money
that somebody gave to
you based on your product
idea without even the product.
Or based on the idea, the
hope, that it will exist
and they will get it.
So the reason I
like this example,
it's a little bit funny.
I'm going to play
this video for you
because this man
is 78 years old.
Is there anyone in here
that's older than 78?
OK, so if he can make a crowd
source funding campaign,
so can you.
And he is actually pretty rich.
He's already made a product
that's done very, very well.
And he could go out there on
his own and build a product
and send it to market without
any help from any of us.
But he was like, I'm not
quite sure if people really
want this, and I'm wondering if
they're willing to pay for it.
So I want to raise money just
to see, and that's what he did.
I'm going to show you this video
just because it's super funny.
How many of you guys think you
should create a crowd source
funding campaign after this?
Yeah?
Well, if you guys
have time, there's
some really good videos,
especially on Indiegogo
site to tell you good tips
and tricks for raising funds.
But I would always
think of this as data.
Again, people often think
of it as fundraising,
but it's very different.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Yuck!
Dog breath.
Let's rewind.
Dogs are adorable, but
they lick everything.
That's why we invented
Orapup, the solution that
helps cure dog breath
in less than a minute.
-Dog bad breath is one of the
major concerns of dog owners.
-All we can really recommend
is to brush their teeth.
People don't do it because
their dogs don't like it.
-Even when they let
you brush their teeth,
it won't solve the problem.
Studies show that 90%
of bad breath in humans
comes from the tongue.
-I'm Dr. Bob.
10 years ago I invented
Orabrush, a tongue cleaner
that helps cure bad breath.
After people started using
the Orabrush for themselves,
they requested that we create
an Orabrush for their dog.
-Orabrush, you need to
make one for dogs now.
That'd be good, wouldn't it?
-How do you get a dog to
let you clean its tongue?
You don't-- you
let the dog do it.
-Having a system where the
dog would clean its own tongue
is very beneficial to both
the owner and to the dog.
-It's not a chore.
It's more like a treat.
-Ultra soft, pointed
bristles clean teeth and--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BRIDGETTE BEAM: All
right, you don't
need to watch the whole thing.
But it's really interesting--
hundreds of thousands of people
contributed to this campaign
in order to buy one of these
before the product existed.
So that's real customer data.
And if I were you,
I would definitely
reconsider how you think
about crowd source funding.
It's not just about
getting funds.
It's really about creating
those first customers.
Creating those
influencers of people
who are going to go out there
and talk about your products.
They're willing to give
you money on a hope.
That's pretty incredible.
So I would think
about this question--
what data drives your startup?
There's a lot of data out there.
You should always have
two numbers every morning
you wake up to that help
you make your decisions.
And you should
always think about
what are the macro forces?
What are the
industry world forces
that make my business
very successful,
or make my business
unsuccessful?
Because I think
too often we know
that there's data
out there, but we
don't take the time to
make it meaningful to us.
And if you guys are a
startup, you have limited time
and you need to figure
out how to do that.
So here's my
exciting takeaways--
it's basically what I just said.
Should have just
turned to the slide.
And that's it.
I'm here all day.
I'm happy to talk about
pretty much anything.
As you see, I like talking, so
that's not a problem for me.
But I'm really glad
you guys joined us.
We really hope to add value.
Each Googler is here to add
value to your company today.
So please take advantage
of that opportunity.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]